[Music]
we're dealing with an expert with guns
with knives with his bare hands Rambo
was the best I finally came home to
defend the only family I've ever known
he must really want this girl
oh she's got this me
she's coming home you started this
I wear tear you apart
this refused thank you
[Music]
right
[Music]
oh hey possum and sorry just you in that
chair I think it would have made a damn
fine president you would have brought a
real dignity to the office you're
welcome America
welcome to Zombieland life is about more
than just survival we were a family
dysfunctional sure but what family isn't
very perfect what would you like little
girl I really like for you to stop
calling me little girl but you know what
I would like I don't give a [ __ ] what
you it felt so good to be on the move
again oh my god I'm so sorry
hi I'm Columbus nothing this is telling
us II hey paul blart this your dad
Oh whoopsie I forgot the seep out wrong
oh so she knows the rules I told her
just a few of her 7300 and are there
more here cute I like it
mister is coming she picked up the boy
he's from Berkeley Berkeley even that
weed Dave do I look like the type of
person that would have weed I'm sorry
whoo yeah have nothing against hippies I
just wanna beat the [ __ ] outta we're
gonna go get her we ride at dawn start
talking you first
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my apologies little Elvis is it me or
does it kind of remind you of I don't
like you at all
I think you double-parked one more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get a
day's going on here
what hello everyone Vilas Nene
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years that you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts you've refused
to die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick you kind
of set it for extinction
maybe so sorry but not today
hey I almost forgot to show you guys
what I found this morning these great
white sharks in their natural habitat
it's awesome this is for turrets you
really want to spend all day on a boat I
am going to take you to a place that no
tourists would ever find in a million
years how did you even find out about
this place
[Music]
ok turn your lights on Sasha you can
barely catch your ass through there at
least I haven't asked the entrance is
dressed at the bottom of the steps you
guys ready for then oh this place is
insane what is that it's an emergency
alarm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen carefully
you are now 5,000 miles from land and
you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean see you all in a
bunch here we go fight for it do this
let's do this
[Music]
with scale from one to ten how bucks my
rig I drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how do we even
get that you walk we're just gonna walk
with insufficient oxygen across the
bottom of the ocean you don't know
what's out there
oh is that
two days ago I had this nice simple life
I know it's a nightmare
[Music]
Sergi
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you
[Music]
my name is Sarah Connor I never seen one
like you before
almost human I am human
don't you care what happens to her
because I was hurt
[Music]
now do we win we win by keeping you
alive
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
throughout time our people robbed lied
and killed until one day we found
ourselves noblemen
but that nobility never came from
chivalry it came from being tough and
ruthless
[Music]
the real power is not found running off
to war
real power lies in understanding who it
is you're truly fighting
[Music]
and how they can be defeated
I know you want to fight but there are
other ways of doing your duty come on
[Music]
we've passed on all we know the thousand
generations live in you now
[Applause]
but this is your fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
always be with you
no one's ever really gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
still talking dear friends it's
complicated
many a dear when we first got together
we were different people
[Music]
bye hey hey Jimmy this is a Martha and
Bethany this is mr. grandfather meet you
morning sergeant on you you're not
barging he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer Vicki went
back in we gotta go get him
huh
what oh you oh my god you're Spencer's
grandfather
are we in Florida Thank You Milo Walker
did I die and turn into some kind of a
small muscular boy scout are we dead my
hip sure feels good now look at us okay
you have some cashews here the game is
busted
who's the game I'm not yet I don't
wonder you welcome to Jumanji
[Music]
this next venture is even more
challenging and remember your job
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji is
that barbers boy little girl we did are
we in hell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the fellows to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity
it's a stupid face you make you having a
heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down let me ask you a question
do you think he black you think them
young people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the streets are war zone
[Music]
you'll be now
[Music]
I gotta me to see I go stay in the car
[Music]
listen you already got rid of everyone
that could talk whoa whoa whoa relax all
cups yeah this isn't what it looks what
you do get a body cam on but we got a
ghost she's gone
I think sad and evil Breland about that
let's get you out of here weed out all
he wants is the body camp
we have been shot what you can't be in
here with this the police they'll help
it was the cops that shot me she cannot
get back to the precinct to upload the
footage on that camera every cop in
criminal in this city is coming to find
her what everybody on
[Music]
got a price on your head what you gonna
do I'm gonna expose
all that is before nothing
this missile plant we're still alive are
we
choice to make right now are you one of
us
he picked her side murders murder don't
matter who you are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the situation in the Pacific
is far worse than reported pearl harbors
the greatest intelligence failure
[Music]
in American history
[Applause]
the Japanese are planning something
bigger so what's the target
we believe it's Midway
Washington disagrees
Washington is wrong
today we're gonna be politics
[Applause]
[Music]
we prove the American Navy as an a joke
[Music]
you'll remember this moment for the rest
of your life
Davida many women can do anything just
because they can doesn't mean they
should
oh just a decoy sir that's just the way
outstanding Angels you have a new client
who is she I can't sleep at night I'm
the lead programmer on a product that
can revolutionize the power industry but
there is a possibility it can be
weaponized ulema will you - no I'm J
who are you embossing
welcome to the pounds of agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can't keep up I don't like
them boy you guys are like lady spies
thanks former mi6 oh god what did you do
to spend my compressed as carotid and
deoxygenated his brain stem
well that sounds painful don't worry
he's gonna wake up unless he doesn't
Sabina runs the ground game sanli stuff
let's get the weapon before it becomes
every bad guy's favorite new toy take
her to the closet cheer her up we're
gonna need some wigs toys
so in the first posit there's another
closet just stop touching some of these
blows up
[Music]
I love phosphorus Jane are you flirting
with a handsome nerd host No
[Music]
how'd that feel because it looks like it
felt really good I feel nice
[Music]
there's morning angels morning charlie
[Music]
you